welcome to salz talks money on
valuetainment economics i'm your host
adam sesnick and i'm here to help you
build your wealth and save that money on
today's episode
sit back relax because we're going for a
ride because it's all about how you
get around let's talk money
so question for you how necessary is it
for you
to have a car that's the question of the
day are we talking a hundred percent you
have to have a car
are you 50 50 hey maybe sure i don't
know what you got to say size i don't
know i'm not sure
or you're like i don't even need a car
i'm good that is the question of the day
today we're going to be covering three
topics number one
car stats in america number 2 the tale
of the tape
car versus uber or rideshare if you will
and number 3
what you should do let's get into it so
ever since henry ford invented the
modern day vehicle
americans love our cars we love our cars
we love our cars
now here's the deal we're so excited
when we turn 16 it's like a rite of
passage
uh coming to age we're 16 it represents
freedom we're leaving the nest we got to
get our license we got to get a car
so what's the point of having a vehicle
people want to get to where they're
going point a to point b
if you will and there's three major
factors what are the three major factors
you ask
well people want to get there safely
they want to get to where they're going
quickly and affordably
so safely quickly and affordably those
are the big three
of getting where you're going so now the
conversation we're gonna have today
did not even exist five years ago
because five years ago you had your car
you were driving your car no question
asked unless you lived in major cities
with public transportation like new york
city or boston you had to have a car it
wasn't even a question
but now things have changed those are
three very powerful words no matter what
you're doing
no matter what industry you're in no
matter what field you're in
things have changed now what's changed
today let's get into it people used to
love getting behind the wheel of their
car
now they love getting in front of their
phone now what else has changed now
since five years ago really now you got
uber you got lyft today you got fricken
covert that's changing
everything people are working remote
they're working from home so the
question is
do you really still need a car i don't
know what are your thoughts
comment below so one thing's for sure we
are no longer living in henry
ford's america now let's get into the
numbers
the average american household has 1.88
cars in the household so that's just
under
two cars per household speaking of cars
what's the average price of a new car
37 grand that's the average price of a
new car how much is a used car
20 000. 37 versus 20
new versus used in 2019 17 million
vehicles
were sold in the united states and get
this what's the best-selling car in
america what do you think it is
i can't hear you well it's the ford
f-150 buddy
welcome to america we love our ford just
like henry ford
now let's talk rideshare when we're
talking ride show we're talking uber and
lyft the big two if you will
the average user takes 5.5
rides per month that equates to 60 to 70
trips
a year that's how many times people are
using uber and lyft all right now i have
a question for you
what percentage of time do you think a
car
is parked that's my question for you
question of the day
what percentage of time do you think a
car is parked the answer is
95 of the time a car
is sitting there being parked not being
driven just sitting there
collecting dust if you will now what
does that equate to
23 out of 24 hours being parked now with
covet it's even higher in fact i went
throughout my garage and my building
just to see how many cars were sitting
there while you're making payments
but collecting dust check out this clip
this is what i would like to call
murderers row
uh in my building it's just a bunch of
bomb-ass
cars that are just sometimes just
sitting here
collecting dust
and leaking car payments let's see what
this bad boy is
now to my next question i asked you at
the very beginning of this episode
how necessary is a car
for you what did you answer did you
comment below well i'll tell you what
most americans have answered
most americans have answered 77 percent
of people think a car
is necessary whereas only 23 percent say
it is not
necessary what are your thoughts
necessary not necessary i'll tell you my
story real quick i haven't had a car
in nine years i used to have an older
mercedes-benz i was trying to stunt
i was trying to look cool it broke down
it was gonna cost me like five grand to
fix it i said screw it
i started taking ubers i started taking
lifts i started taking the train
and i have saved so much money that i've
started a whole show
called save that money so in this
episode today we're gonna take it to the
tape where we're gonna do
car versus uber why do they call it car
versus uber because
people understand what uber is but
obviously we mean ride share we mean
lift we mean anything
other than having a car now let's get in
the tail of the tape the first topic is
your car payment let's break down what
it costs to own
a car now for a new car payment today
the average cost is 550 bucks
for a used car you're talking 390 bucks
and for a lease aka a fleece you're
talking 450 bucks a month the problem
with the leases
you pay you pay you pay you never own
the car so you just keep paying and
paying and paying and paying
forever that's the whole deal with the
car payment those are the average car
payments
now when you're talking an uber this is
where all the numbers and the stuff is
going down i'm going to break it down
for you
this is what it costs per ride there's
actually a crazy formula i'm going to
read it to you real quick it's the base
fare
plus time rate plus distance rate times
the surge multiplier plus tolls
plus fees aka booking fee that's how
they determine how much you'll be
spending
on a lift or uber now just a little
further information for you the average
cost of a lift
average ride is 12.50 versus an
uber the average ride is 13.30 cents
so those are the big costs right there
you got the monthly car payment
versus the average ride for a ride share
so here's the catch
how many times are you using the uber or
lyft
that's up to you let's get into the next
topic which is finance
charges the average finance charge
according to aaa is 670
a year that equates to 4.3 percent that
you're paying
in interest now what's the finance
charges for
an uber or lyft and a it stands for not
applicable that's going to be a common
theme
in many of the different categories here
with uber moving on
the next topic we got is down payment
how much is the average down payment for
a car
well it's 10 to 20 depending on what
kind of car you're getting depending on
what kind of vehicle you're getting
what does that equate to what we just
said the average car used cars 20 000
the average new car is 37 000 so you're
talking on average two
to five thousand dollars for a down
payment now if you're talking lyft and
uber
how much is the down payment and a not
applicable zero dollar
now we got insurance that's a big one
the average car insurance in america
today is seventeen hundred
fifty dollars that equates to a hundred
and forty five dollars
a month depending on your driving record
that's a big one how much is your car
insurance for an uber or lyft
n a not applicable zero dollars
congratulations now we're talking gas
how much gas
are you spending per month per car
you're talking a little under
1700 a year on gas
that equates to 140 a month that's 11
cents a mile
let me check how much the gas is on uber
at lyft not applicable zero dollars
you're paying nothing
you get the message here here we go
moving right along now let's talk
maintenance how much is the average
maintenance per year for car well it's
910 dollars what comes with maintenance
well you know it if you have a car
you're talking oil changes
tires batteries tune-ups up keep that's
what comes with maintenance how much is
maintenance on a lift or uber
and a not applicable you're not paying
for that here we go
last thing taxes tag title how much are
you paying on average
670 bucks a year that varies state by
state you get it certain states are
higher certain states are lower
how much is it on lift or uber not
applicable save that money here we go
moving right along let's talk about
upgrades now here's where things
might differ upgrades when you're
talking upgrades for your car you're
talking accessories what kind of
accessories or modifications
are we talking about here we're talking
tents we're talking rims we're talking
exhausts we're talking systems you want
to look good you want to look fresh
cool we get it that's going to cost you
a pretty penny moving right along
now we got some charges they're going to
cost you with the lift and uber now we
got some charges
maybe you want to upgrade you want to
look good you got a hot date you got a
big meeting you got it what are you
going to do you want to look good
you might have an uber lux you might
have a lift suv you might have a lyft
or uber black car that might cost you
double or triple
what you're typically paying right there
so that's the first charge
that's like hold on is this uber or lyft
really worth it i don't know because if
i want a really really dope car
to get around with where i'm going that
might cost me extra moving right along
let's talk about parking now what i have
here is
low medium and high because parking
depends on where you're at sometimes
parking is free cool you park at your
friend's house you park it a city street
that's free parking no big deal then you
got medium parking now it's short term
right you might
have uh pay a meter or you might have to
pay valet maybe you're talking 5 10 20
bucks no big deal
but then you got high stuff maybe you're
talking daily fees you got to pay for
an office visit all day or you're
working all day that might cost you 40
50 60 bucks depending on the city you're
in
parking does add up moving right along
how much is parking would lift well we
get the point here
and a not applicable because you pull up
they drop you off get out of the car
you're not paying for parking
keep it moving moving right along this
is a big thing here this is maybe the
big thing
let's talk about convenience when you're
talking about convenience about having a
car
you're self-reliant it's on you you come
and go as you please you do what you
want to do you don't got to get in a car
with anybody else
who's this driver i'm not so sure can i
trust them can i not trust them
it's on you okay cool no big deal the
one catch with that is
don't text and drive you got that okay
now talking about convenience with the
lift or uber you're dependent
on the driver it's not on you you can't
come and go as you please you got to
wait for them to pick you up
you're driving with a stranger do you
know them do you not know them i don't
know can you trust them you're in the
back seat
who knows some people are creeped out by
these things some people i don't give a
it's all good
here's the catch though you can text and
drive and work while you're driving
so that is some sort of convenience
while someone else is driving moving
right along
let's talk about worst case scenario
this is a big
thing so pay attention now big thing
this is the last thing you want with
your car you get a flat tire you're on
the side of a road you're waiting on
aaa to come fix a tire do you know how
to change a tire all of a sudden you're
dealing with maybe an accident god
forbid someone backed into you
your car's in the shop you're dealing
with that crap god forbid
worst case scenario you'll get a dui
that might cost you five
ten thousand dollars to deal with the
dui that is a nightmare situation
you would likely want to avoid okay
understand that okay so now what's worst
case scenario with a lifter uber well
maybe the driver cancels they get lost
you go the wrong route you charge a
little bit extra you got to get a refund
that's a worst case scenario
maybe you're wasted you puke in the car
you got to pay 200 bucks
because you puked in someone's car
that's worst case scenario i don't know
about you
but worst case scenario over here is a
lot worse than this worst case scenario
that's just my opinion i don't know what
do you think
now let's talk about depreciation this
is a huge
factor when you have a car depreciation
i don't know if you know this but a car
is a depreciating asset let me say that
again a car
is a depreciating asset the average cost
of a car 30 000
that's for a new car after the first
year
it depreciates 30 and then it
depreciates 15
year after year after year you bought a
car for 30 grand
next thing you know it's five years
later and it's only worth 12 grand
that's how depreciation
works now how much is depreciation on
your lifter uber
well it's n a zero zero depreciation
because it's not your car all good last
but not least let's talk about
total cost we've done the math we've run
the numbers
here's the total cost of having a car on
average per year
so the average cost of a car to own a
car total
all the way down 8 500 per year
okay so if you're doing basic math here
you're talking you're spending between
400 and 500 dollars between a new car
used car all your
so if you do the math on that that only
comes out to about four or five grand
but a car costs you 8 500 bucks a year
well we just did the math
all these things add up moving right
along let's talk about the total cost
of an uber or lift well it comes out to
about four thousand dollars a year
that's if
you're taking a car three to four trips
a week that's just basic math right
there so the total cost
favors lift or uber versus having a car
but the question is what should you
do let's break these two things down now
what we have here is who should be
having a car
and who should be just ubering around
uber everywhere uber everywhere
let's get into who should have a car now
who should have a car
if you're going long distances if you
have a long commute if you're in the car
for a half hour hour you're driving
places
you've got a long commute that will add
up in an uber or lift that's probably
not for you
if you're taking multiple daily trips
you're going to the store then you're
going for
lunch and then you got to go get some
milk then you got to pick up your kids
if you're making multiple daily trips
that can get really really annoying in a
car or
uber next thing is if there's limited
public transportation around you maybe
you're in a rural area
you don't have subways or buses or
trains anywhere near you maybe you need
to have a car
what else if you want to have pride if
you want to kind of do your thing and
you want to have a sense of ownership
and stability and you want to have
status status is a big thing
then maybe you need to have a car i get
it last but not least
family if you got a family with kids and
pets and pile them in the car
and you're doing your thing then you
probably want to take the whole family
in an uber and a lift i get it
however here's the catch maybe you only
need one
car for the whole family i don't know
what are your thoughts on that we just
established at the very beginning here
that the average
household has 1.88 cars just under two
cars
but i know a lot of people are just
saying you know what screw it i'm just
doing one car
these days for the family we'll save
that money and we'll uber elsewhere
that's an option moving right along who
should uber now
if you're living a short distance from
where you're going if you live close to
the office maybe you're only
5-10 minutes from the office you should
definitely consider
uber especially these days if you're
working from home if you're working
remote the car is sitting there 95
percent of the time
collecting dust you don't have a long
drive you maybe need to think about
ubering
everywhere you go if you're only taking
a few daily trips no big deal if you're
in an office all day
if you have access to public
transportation if you can easily just
jump in a subway
or a train or a bus no big deal you can
maybe just uber and not have a car
obviously if you're single it's just you
you're doing your thing you don't got
kids you don't got a family
it's probably easy to uber i've done
that it works for me will it work for
you last but not least
drinking obviously if you're drinking
you want to avoid a dui i don't care if
you have a car
or not have a car don't be caught
drinking and driving avoid that dui
definitely use an uber okay so you've
seen the numbers you've seen the stats
you've seen the figures the only
question is this
what works best for you only you can
answer that
so here's my final takeaway the
beautiful thing these days is you have
options you have choices this is
capitalism at its finest if you want to
have a car
have a car if you want an uber you want
to lift you want to take a subway
do what works best for you you have
options that's a beautiful thing number
two
i encourage you to do these three words
do the
math do the math do the math and see how
much
it's actually costing you to have a car
have you done the math i'm asking you
do you even know what you're paying in
all these expenses do the math when it
comes to lift and uber am i taking this
too much is it not enough i don't know
do the math that's a major major thing
and last but not least after you do the
math
make sure you add it all up and you save
that money that's what we're all about
here as you know
now if you have not seen my video on
whether it's better for you to rent or
buy
check out this video right here or if
you have not seen my video on how to
invest in the stock market
today check that out right here and if
you have not subscribed to valuetainment
economics
please subscribe below and smash that
like button
while you're at it and as always make
sure you save
that money all we talk is money